Emma you said in a prior interview about
I am breathing that upon watching the
film a writer from The Telegraph
proclaimed how a dying man taught me to
live so Louise tell us about you know
your life with Neal your life with Oscar
how this film came about um
well Neal and I were very happy with
which only just heard Oscar in 2007 and
then in the in the August of 2007 and
then I think it was in October that Neal
came home one day and he was aware that
he had a strange limp strange because it
wasn't connected to any pain in any way
so we sort of thought maybe he needs a
new pair of shoes
we went out bought my new pair of shoes
and then Monday morning the same thing
happened and that day he sort of came
home and immediately took off his socks
and shoes and had a good look and we
realized that he couldn't lift his big
tool on one foot as high as he could on
the other foot and that was the
beginning off it really so slowly from
then it it crept up his body and so
Oscar was only two months old at that
first symptom and then it it said I'm
slowly or rather quickly actually took
hold of him and he died when I was 18
months old and I understand was that
February was at 2007 that the incident
happened with the food and I know that
that would be in October in 2007 and
Neal died February 2009 Wow and and my
understanding was that it was so quick
that by Christmas was it he was using a
walking that Christmas he was using a
walking stick and
and and really finding it quite
difficult to walk he described it as a
waddle he had to kind of roll his hips
around to be able to walk and I know by
April I think we he was on crutches and
then June June or July he was in a
wheelchair pretty much full time and
then I think it was somewhere between
July and beginning of September he he
began to need to use a ventilator and
for two sisters breathing and then by
November I think of that year he was on
the ventilator as life support he was
needing it 24 hours a day he would
really struggle if when changing and
cleaning the mask if if there was any
more than about 40 seconds and changing
the mask so and teeth also by November
had lost the ability to move his arms as
well and I think then by Christmas he
was also losing the ability to hold his
head up and so his head was just we had
to support his head all the time as well
so by the time he died in February he
really had practically no movement left
apart from his lower jaw and his eyes
and the expression on his face and I
understand with MND which is is it motor
neuron disease it's what we call it
motion yearand disease yes I think in
America and and in most other countries
actually I think it's called ALS and
your son right here is the Gehrig's
disease I understand I think in the film
you talked about feeling everything but
not being able to move and his mind is
intact so he would have an itch or
something couldn't
yeah I think unlike other and people are
paralyzed he could still feel every
single every single part of his body and
it also became a little bit more
sensitive as well because his hands
because they hadn't been used for a
while the skin would be very sensitive
so I would lift his hand up to feel
Oscars hair and he would say it just
feels like straw in my hands and those
things were really sad actually
yeah at what point did you meet Emma
Neal and I had both well we've met when
we were both studying at Edinburgh
College of Arts and we had a good friend
moeraki MacKinnon and she had just been
down to visit us at the house when Neil
put a call out on his blog to say I need
to get this disease out there I need to
talk about it we need to raise awareness
anybody that has any any contacts and
the media newspapers anything at all
please come and ask me please let me
speak and more I read this blog that he
he published and and it was really more
accurate thought well I'm a fiction
director but I do have a good friend
Emma who heard me documentary before and
and more I contacted both of Australian
and just set the idea alight and I think
instantly Neil was interested in doing
in doing the documentary you weren't so
injured well he were interested in your
hand so I was probably the most
reluctant one out of everybody there I
suppose just because of experience
knowing what an undertaking it is for
the family and just I suppose also
wondering whether it was the right thing
to do to make a story out of his
suffering really
but it was interesting in a week because
I think the doubts actually more egg and
I talked an awful lot because we had a
long journey from Edinburgh to Yorkshire
where Louisa Newburgh we're living at
the time and every car journey we talked
why are we taking the cameras into this
house what's this about and gradually I
think you know young covered really
valid reasons to make the film I know
that in the film he says that he wanted
Oscar your son to know who he was that
he had lost his own father and had
questions I think that's very valuable
especially coming from myself I've lost
my father so you don't know who that
person is and it's a huge part of
yourself that's missing but he also had
a message for the world he wanted people
I think to know not just about the
disease but also to know how fast time
yeah yeah I mean I think it really
became a focus for Neal to just spread
awareness he was a very driven person he
was a very sociable person as you can
tell from the film I mean a great sense
of humor he realized that he could see
you know he could spread the word about
the disease and and it really became
very important to him to do that I am
and you know he does say in the film
that he felt guilty almost that he
hadn't done anything since his father
died up to the point that he was
diagnosed and I think that added to him
really wanting to do the documentary and
speak about the disease
you